yeah
enticing keep a vote on it camisa
mr.strimer oka Heba thank you madam
president
another important subject of course of a
slightly different kind honourable
members thank you for this opportunity
to a contribute to the debate ahead of
the vote on a resolution later this week
I am of course very concerned about the
recent imposition of tariffs by the US
on a range of our agri-food export I
know from direct contacts that you are
to this imposition by the US on tariffs
of food and drink is a regrettable
development although the US have
formally the legal right to impose these
tariffs for a long long time the
Commission has been engaging with the
u.s. to ask them to freeze or to suspend
this in order to find a negotiated
solution to the Boies a Boeing Airbus
dispute we made a credible offer in July
for a negotiated settlement as you know
this is an a case that has been going on
for many many years
unfortunately this opportunity has not
been taken up by the US yet we believe
that it's time to turn the page on this
dispute and focus on de-escalating
tensions rather than adding further
uncertainty to a delicate world trade an
economic situation I hope that goodwill
still will prevail we are committed to
find a solution which will keep trade
flowing and workers on both sides of the
Atlantic to be able to keep their jobs
and this has been the aim to remind
mandate and I'm unconvinced that Phil
Hogan will continue these efforts he
will go to the to Washington in early
new year to engage and to continue to
engage with members of the US
administration the for us EU member
states where Airbus manufacturing is
concentrated UK France Germany and Spain
together with Italy and Ireland account
for 95 percent of the total food exports
of the 3.5 billion euros exposed to the
tariffs and the target products in order
magnitudes branch from wine spirit
liquors daily products and olive oils
and these products are highly valued by
US consumers and we hope that the demand
from them will help resist price
pressures addressing directly the calls
made in your draft resolution there are
measures available under the cup that
could be used to mitigate the impact of
sanctions in the market we are reviewing
the appropriate of direct intervention
at this stage because you have to take
into account a number of consideration
for instance we need to clearly
distinguish between difficulties that
are directly related to the US tariffs
and those which are related to other
issues for instance we recently
introduced private storage aid for
virgin olive oils in the EU open for all
olive oil producing Member States the US
tariffs have certainly aggravated a very
serious situation but the underlying
reasons for the introduction of this
measures are not directly related to the
Airbus case we also need to take account
to the wider development of the WTO in
relation to the u.s. measures including
the possibilities that the Boeing case
will present later next year but we
remain having the first preference of a
negotiated settlement because thereby we
would avoid damaging trade dispute and
we would also provide a powerful signal
to the world market that we want to keep
world trade flowing when it comes to the
specific measures that we could take
promotion policies often a very
appropriate response to tariff sanctions
offering operators the possibility to
consolidate the market or to rent Ain
their position on existing markets or
even to seek new opportunities and you
mentioned this in your referral
resolution and the recently adopted
twenty20 annual work program emphasizes
promotion campaigns in third market by
allocating almost 2/3 of the available
funding to them that is 180 million
euros and in response to the concerns
expressed by some of you here
in relation to the u.s. Chaves impact on
wine Commissioner Hogan last week
confirmed that he providing greater
flexibility in the implementation and
management a promotion of operation
seems to be an appropriate response to
market disturbances which are likely to
affect the wine sector and this
flexibility includes a proposal to
increase the union financing rate for
promotion to 60% instead of 50 today
which will alleviate the financial
burden on producers the Commission has
reacted rapidly to the urgency and
seriousness of the situation and we hope
that we can count on your support to
ensure a smooth and swift adopted
adoption of the required regulation so
that this flexibility can be applied
quickly to the benefit of our producers
other than our promotion policy the cap
toolbox also includes certain market
management instruments such as private
storages Madam President the Commission
is aware that additional measures might
have to be considered following the
conclusions of the analysis there were
right now doing on the situation of the
agriculture markets we do this with the
sectors and with the member states
concerned and where the analysis
suggests we are ready to activate
exceptional market measures including
private storages in the meantime I want
to show you that this commission and the
incoming Commission myself and my friend
and colleague Phil Hogan will do our
best to find a negotiated balanced
sustainable and compatible solution with
the WTO rules and one that would put an
end to the damage suffered by European
farmers including our wine producers
Thank You Kita's commissary Malstrom
yeah Victor Zillmer if me and whoever
owned in Yahoo was in Iran enzymatic
sienta who have our on a paper male
yeah senator usted Juan Ignacio Roy
dough Alvarez cocksman al Kaba